you are watching the press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive in the next half hour
we'll see what's making the headlines
with the journalist and author rachel
shabby and the editor of spiked tom
slater so let's see what's on some of
those front pages for you now the
express reports that boris johnson is
promising the government will take big
bold decisions on jobs crime health and
social care as conservatives gather for
the start of the party's conference in
manchester
the observer leads with a group of
conservative mps telling the prime
minister he can't increase prosperity in
poorer parts of the uk while raising
taxes and cutting benefits
the pm is to rush through laws to stop
protesters blocking motorways according
to the mail with the headline boris our
lockup activists blocking the road
the telegraph says coronavirus travel
restrictions will change this week and
claims the 54 countries on the
government's red list will be cut to as
few as nine
the mirror claims an investigation into
the metropolitan police has found 26
colleagues of murderer wayne cousins
have committed sex crimes since 2016.
the times says sarah everard's killer
was given an access all areas pass at
the houses of parliament on a number of
occasions when he was deployed to guard
mps
care homes have faced a christmas crisis
reports the people with up to 42 000
workers at risk of being sacked for not
having a covered vaccination
and the star has a story about dad's
army actor frank williams
and we are joined now by rachel shabby
and tom slater good evening to you both
welcome
let's start with the observer and that
story that we mentioned there running
through the the papers of conservative
mps actually you know going against
boris johnson breaking ranks and saying
that really
you can't level up by taxing the poor
and uh cutting benefits rachel
yes that's right so this is ahead of the
conservative annual conference in
manchester
um there's a breakaway group of mps and
this includes mps who
uh in the last in the 2019 election took
long-standing labor seats uh across the
north and the midlands
um and they are exactly as you say
challenging uh boris johnson and
expecting to challenge him at this
conference by by saying
look how is your
leveling up so-called agenda going to
work
if you know in the last few months we've
had increases in tax so national
insurance
and also cuts to benefits particularly
the universal credit uplift which is set
to be cut
um that's coming into effect on
wednesday um and so this group of mps is
led by jack berry from the northern
research group and that's a group of
some 50 mps across across the northeast
and you have to say that they've got a
point i mean we're all feeling uh
economic anxiety at the moment in the
middle of a fuel crisis spiraling energy
costs um furlough just ended um
the fuel cap has just risen and so a lot
of people are feeling a lot of anxiety
and i just don't think if you are
serious about a leveling up
agenda i don't think you can do that
unless you have a specific plan
for state intervention
to
tackle some of those very very deep
inequalities and injustices
tom do you think this group of tory mps
have a point and will the prime minister
be able to persuade them otherwise at a
conference in manchester
well i think i definitely have a point
on the immediate circumstances that
people find themselves in as
rachel was just referring to there but
also what was supposed to be different
about this conservative government we've
heard a lot about leveling up but so far
it's really been a kind of slogan in
search of some substance michael gove
has been brought in as essentially the
secretary of state to leveling up in
order to try and give it some substance
what does it actually mean we get that
it's about investing in quite unquote
left behind regions of the uk investing
in infrastructure investing in skills
but boris johnson has hung all kinds of
different issues off of it he talks
about crime as a matter of leveling up
he talks about everything as if it's a
matter of leveling up so aside from the
kind of immediate squeeze on living
standards and particularly the people
who've
been in
uh receipt of that universal credit
uplift who are going to be potentially
plunged into some serious hardship as a
result of that ending there's this
broader thing about how do you not only
just look after people in the here and
now but actually build that greater
prosperity because if
again no substance can be given to that
agenda then it looks like the tories
will squander that opportunity they had
to really carve out those working-class
former labour seats as a new base for
them but they only lent the tories their
vote so the question is can they keep it
and i think there's a lot of disquiet
amongst tory benches at the moment as to
whether there is a clear plan for doing
so let's move on to the sunday telegraph
uh and this article looking at the fact
that uh travel
is opening up again uh quarantine
abolished for almost all countries as uh
boris johnson prepares for postcovid
normality rachel
that's right so the prime minister wants
to take the remaining 54 countries
currently on the red list
most of them um he plans to remove from
that red list leaving perhaps only nine
or so countries still there so countries
such as south africa brazil and mexico
will come off the list thailand most
likely um worth remembering that you
know across across the uk lots of people
have got family um in those countries
that are in in on the red list and so
you know i haven't been able to see
loved ones for a very very long time so
that will be welcome news but also worth
remembering that that that doesn't
eliminate you know what happens at the
other end necessarily and also all the
sort of hurdles quite costly hurdles of
um pcr tests um perhaps at this end
perhaps at the other end um still making
travel
really out of reach for for a lot of
people
yeah it's not complete opening up
because uh travellers to countries
remaining on on the red list will still
need to to quarantine um potentially in
a hotel on their return to the uk tom
yes so if you do have the disadvantage
of ending up in one of those reckless
countries when things shift um you're
actually
having to
pay for that most extreme form of
quarantine that we've all read about and
it's it's important that we're making
this step i think as rachel was
suggesting there are still major hurdles
and i think one big thing we're going to
have to get over in the sort of post
covered era is making sure that flying
and travel and international travel not
just for holidays but to see family and
all the rest of it doesn't go back to
just being the preserve of the middle
class and the rich as it was until
relatively recently really so in terms
of these kind of pcr testings these
various hurdles you hope that they're
overcome quickly because as rachel was
saying you know it's like a third of
kids born in england and wales now have
a foreign-born mother this isn't just
about people getting two weeks in the
sun it's about people seeing their
families so important we're heading in
this direction but it's not over yet but
it looks a bit
uh more details being released about
wayne cousins the the murder of sarah
everard in the sunday times uh and this
latest detail is the fact that he worked
at the house of of commons and had a a
pass on on several occasions looking
after mps protecting mps rachel
that's right i mean this story has been
absolutely chilling for days i know
women across the country have just been
so disturbed by this and just find it
impossible to to shake off because it is
absolutely chilling and now these
revelations uh scotland yard has
admitted for the first time that wayne
cousins
had duties um he was a police officer
who was deployed to guard mps in
westminster and was thought to have
done that at least five times in the
last year i believe this is this is just
absolutely awful i mean you'd think that
parliament would be one of the safest
places obviously mps have that
expectation and staff all the staff that
are at parliament as well
absolutely awful uh to think
that this was the case and you know the
newspapers sunday papers are full of
all kinds of fresh revelations about
wayne cousins and also um some comments
from uh police about proposals for for
very much needed reform and review yes
and very quickly tom um the common so
lindsey hoyle uh quoted as saying that
he's extremely concerned by the the new
disclosures and would be seeking answers
from from christa dick
no and rightly so i mean as rachel was
saying you would expect the vetting for
all kinds of different things to be much
more heightened around the houses of
commons in relation to everything from
terrorism through to obviously the
questions around sexual misconduct
sexual assault his own proclivities so
the fact that even in that environment
cousins wasn't showing up on these
vetting procedures raising some very
serious questions for the met definitely
welcome back you're watching the press
preview still with me rachel shabby and
tom slater there they both are um let's
continue talking about the mets handling
of the sarah everard
killing
we've got
a piece in the sunday telegraph with uh
robert buckland the former justice
secretary saying that that mets attempt
to put the onus on women to keep
themselves safe is repugnant and that
does seem to be the
the the way many people feel about that
the advice that the met has been giving
people women on what to do if they feel
unsafe rachel
i think repugnant is a really good word
for it and it will certainly sum up the
reaction of many women um
watching the
police response particularly the met
police response to this um and
again putting the onus on women um
telling women
to
wave down a bus for instance if they're
worried about a police officer who has
apprehended them
all kinds of measures and you just think
this is absolutely appalling this is
gaslighting women across the country the
onus
is not on women here it's on the police
and i feel really annoyed and angry that
the whole week
the response has been just to minimize
and dismiss and it actually shows you
uh the scale of the problem with this
culture of misogyny and of just not
taking these issues seriously enough
um so we've had a week of um
[Music]
the met police trying to minimize this
as well by saying that wayne cousins was
you know some kind of bad apple whereas
the reality is that you know this is
something that isn't endemic it's
institutional it's a cultural issue and
the fact that the police forces are
trying to
dismiss in this way just wanted to bring
tommen on that point of it being endemic
because the mirror um tells us that 26
colleagues of wayne cousins have
committed sex crimes in
since 2016. this is a the probe into the
met police so
as rachel what was saying tommy it does
seem as if this is endemic in in the
police force
well i think we have to hold the police
to a higher standard than pretty much
anyone who works in public life because
of the powers that they are lent because
of the amount of trust that that rests
on and because of the high cost when
that is betrayed both for individuals
and for society more broadly i think the
response from the met has been tin-ed
but i think it's also the reason that
this particular crime strikes so much of
the everyone's humanity really it feels
so depraved it feels so horrendous it's
because crimes of this nature of this
scale and involving serving police
officers are so rare that's why they
shock us so much you can understand and
whilst you know i'm never hold back from
criticizing the police you can
understand why there's this desperate
desire to say we are not like this and
even in his sentencing remarks the
justice who handed down that whole life
order made a point of the investigation
of there was no attempt to close ranks
around this to minimize any
embarrassment so yes the response from
the met has been teenaged has been
ridiculous it's basically sending the
signal if nothing else that people
should that women should be afraid of
them
which is a ridiculous and horrendous
state of affairs but we do need to
remember that this is a very singular
crime that's why it's so incredibly
shocking and whilst there are practical
lessons that should be made from it i
think an attempt to over politicize it
in this way could end up doing more harm
than good
rachel very quickly just uh i've got
time for a very short section on the
sunday times and this is um a new law
to make hrt free on prescription for
women just your thoughts very quickly on
that
yes labour mp carolyn harris i think she
has enough support for a private
member's bill on this um i think it's a
great move um
hrt
uh prescriptions are 10 pounds but hrt
and i know because i'm i'm taking it
it's actually two sets of prescriptions
so that's 20 pounds um and it is a lot
and it's already a lot to be dealing
with carolyn harris is saying that um
when she thought she was having a
nervous breakdown when she was
menopausal because she just didn't know
how to recognize the symptoms so i think
there's still a lot of work to do on
this uh to help women
um
when it comes to when it comes to
dealing with this rachel tom thank you
both for the moment see a little later
on let's take a look at the weather for
you
you